[Music]
so in fatal stunt news
Oh only members word in submitted by
Ashley Tran a teen has been charged
after shooting her boyfriend during a
failed YouTube's not what what was it
one of those like I got a bulletproof
vest shoot me and then the miss and it's
like or is it one of those [ __ ]
chubby bunnies and he [ __ ] [ __ ]
ramen challenge oh it is terrible that
was Yoda but this is real a comedian one
more time uh this is a big youtuber or
someone trying to make it on you to try
to make it how old with it okay so this
couple from Minnesota Meany sure that
it's Mona Lisa and her boyfriend Petra
name yes Mona Lisa to ruin or that's not
they're reporting on Mona Lisa this is
Mona Lisa and Pedro 19 and 20 of not 19
damn she looks like his mama she's 19
David okay fine Mona Lisa currently
pregnant with their second child
oh [ __ ] four year old daughter damn 16
yes so they started a YouTube channel
some Minnesota life I guess mm-hmm okay
[Laughter]
YouTube channel and on you know home to
show the real life of a young couple who
happens to be teen parent that's cool
yeah and so a lot of their videos are
involved doing pranks stunt three
challenges let's thank the baby no you
don't know this but you only got one
shoe on
hahaha yes only pranks were that easy we
had on the babies I don't know what's
going on yeah so you can see a little
girl in the back barrel so for this
particular stunt Mona Lisa is saying
that Pedro has been begging her to do
this for a while she kept saying no
because hello dangerous so what he
wanted to do up off the top of the head
no so what you wanted
her to do is shoot a gun at a book that
he was holding right over his foot away
but away was a challenge any it was it
look was gonna stop the bullet there's
like a stunt like it's like a super is
like an encyclopedia why didn't they
just shoot the book first to test it she
is claiming that he had shown her a book
fullest I was a fifty caliber 50 caliber
Desert Eagle oh yeah bro does it have a
[ __ ] dumb that fool is like that's
all you explain how powerful is that
mini cannon I felt like I was gonna
break my wrist when I said it yeah
explain to them so okay you know when
you like in the movies people hide
behind walls that she doesn't work like
even with like a 9 mil or 45 and someone
right next to you on the other side of
this drywall I'll just blast them and
kill them and then this is a 50 council
it's way stronger than that [ __ ] you
were going to need like 10 phone books
back-to-back to stop the bullet so to
put in perspective you can probably
shoot through a cylinder block or brick
with this yes they will go through the
brick and he had like an encyclopedia I
get a password I read it was like
sobbing cyclopædia yeah restaurant menu
if it was a 22 caliber maybe if it was a
Chinese phone book maybe hold the Bible
next to your chest I swear to god Costa
today's to spent all my gosh she has
been charged with second-degree did he
die he dies oh my bullet dude he's dead
man yeah when they were filming this
they had set up a GoPro on one side and
then a camera on a ladder on the other
and they apparently did this in front of
their three years and so I'll do it when
was she wearing earmuffs Kelly's not
sure just touching alone like the bill
price copper heart or something it's
[ __ ] loud this one either doesn't
sound right or number two it sounds like
you wanted to die very much yeah or or
he's just really [ __ ] dumb right
or that I just can't believe he's done
because there's something a little bit
off he showed her a book that he shot
through that that it was safe that means
he lied to her
no I didn't no way he shot a [ __ ]
what well yeah because I'd like to see
the book that stopped the 50 Cal cuz I
don't know any [ __ ] book that could
stop a 50 Cal yeah earlier in the day
she tweeted is evolution me and Pedro
are probably going to shoot one of the
most dangerous videos ever his idea not
to fans is a still from one of her
videos crazy petrol crazy so now I want
to find out the nitty-gritty like is it
a suicide thing for him like intentional
suicide think Nick I could feel that
yeah that's what I feel like was he just
back down because if they had that book
with that bullet hole before it then I
could believe it because you might have
shot another gun and he just gets all
phone books will stop all guns and it
was like a really weak learners what if
yeah he shot like a 22 and he goes you
know what in the middle of it he changes
production and he goes you know what's
next level is we used Desert Eagle I
just don't want anybody shooting
anything at me not even those guns
like I sell [ __ ] and why don't worry
stress like that's so dumb my gosh and
would it tugged away kicks she could
have missed the book altogether that's a
really good point that's a great [ __ ]
aim it was only a foot away but feel
heavy it's a yes gun yeah so they're
saying that once exchange saw him she
called 911 herself and let police know
what happened and so they rushed over
they confiscated the footage and which
will never be released obviously and so
now she faces a maximum of 10 years or
signed a $20,000 or both what about baby
I know what babies should be pregnant in
prison that's why you see the lady jails
with the playgrounds and it's really
weird because you see all the like
barbed wire fence but then there's a
playground inside because the ladies
they raise their children inside jail
I'm so sad
but should she be in real trouble if I
gotta get it she killed him but if you
have footage of him staying there like
agreeing to it I was like shoot me shoot
me already
that's what what it was that she got
manslaughter involuntary
she got second-degree manslaughter oh I
feel like this should be involved yeah I
feel I feel like we should have a rule
that's like stupidity laws if you if you
stupid then maybe like we're down here
because you're intent it's all about
intent yeah apparently as a manslaughter
is it's an unlawful killing that doesn't
involve malice aforethought or serious
harm or kill or extreme reckless
disregard for interesting that's a nice
honor in ten years for that when I went
to the chiropractor I'm reading on the
[ __ ] and technically they can kill you
different you sign away because like if
they do something wrong with your spine
and you end up [ __ ] snap this up
bleeding out and dying you signed
consent yeah and they don't get in
trouble for that even I should though
that's just loose you could give the bid
against Tillich in trouble for like
malpractice you can't prove that they
just didn't do the [ __ ] right it's is
how far people are going now to like do
stunts no like they could get views they
could go viral they could like in hopes
of being famous and all that [ __ ] and
it's like that's why I don't care about
that [ __ ] man because I know a lot
of fake-ass bloggers out there and I
know a lot of fake-ass pranksters out
there I'm gonna say who but you know who
the [ __ ] you are you [ __ ] lying sack
of [ __ ] I don't participate in that
[ __ ] all over whatever uh
significally all except for the ones
with all games I know people that don't
take that [ __ ] like simple pick ups be
green they don't fake in all their
production is [ __ ] is real but now so
there's so many [ __ ] fakes out there
that they that people just come on
trying to critique their [ __ ] so
apparently Pedro's aunt was telling the
media that she knew about this
beforehand and she kept saying like dot
like don't do this it was dangerous and
why would you do this and that
apparently he told her that it was
because they want more viewers and they
want to get famous see I'm so [ __ ]
dumb be parented you know it's hard
though because this this is the issue
and I've always I've mentioned this many
times when when YouTube in the creative
space started it was about creating for
yourself and creating for what you
thought was really great and cat videos
and
and and and dogs with people speaking
yeah the creativity on YouTube years ago
was amazing because there was no channel
like somebody else's now if not about
creating for yourself and creating from
personal life stories is about seeing
what anybody else is doing and copying
it right and as such because yeah you
could do what other people are doing in
that kind of sense but there's no even
even then there's no creative take on it
it's just whatever I can do to get
somebody to watch me and that's where
you to start becoming an artist space
you know it started becoming a little
bit more like this that's where my issue
is so like your people ask me do you
watch YouTube there's like no I don't I
don't watch it anymore because
everybody's channel the same I said
we're just kidding news Timothy
DeLaGhetto would you shut my channel to
Dave's or Connie I'm sorry whatever a
generalist o7j tipping cave but a Jill
oh the best Oh John I don't know what
I'm talking about anything that involves
any of these things everybody just wants
retweets and they want like this quick
notoriety that's why you have like kids
like setting themselves on fire for some
challenge unless you're dumbest [ __ ] man
they just want the retweets like for
what yeah I want to be famous I don't
want the fame I just wanted to make
funny [ __ ] and then like live a
lifestyle that's like free that's cool
and to produce create whatever the [ __ ]
I want and I'm gonna say if you're gonna
if you want the quick same like don't do
something to hurt yourself because are
you mom like getting out girl I hate
being annoying [ __ ] not one that's
hurt other people hurt your parents and
get on a TV show yeah do something less
like more destructive but safer right
yeah talk some [ __ ] or you you would you
can do you could hit me up in my email
and then tell me that you want to do a
video where I [ __ ] sock your face as
hard as possible you're a killer
and I don't know no no no no it'll be
David so Carboni punches random person
in the face give me 30 G's and I'll do
it and you'll be things hope you guys
enjoyed that video but if you didn't
guess what you can directly contribute
to the articles that we discussed just
cruise out over to the description box
below click on that link to submit your
article also for the next video click
right up
you
[Music]